right and we know that bk has a we saw
his first match to qualify for top eight
he was very wild i've played in myself
as well he's very good at using moves
that you don't usually see with um with
gas as well so let's get into it i never
knew that gigas had a hot kick i never
knew he could do that
and i wonder how much these guys have
played against as well you know because
they've bought some saudi arabia yeah
they played in tournaments yeah it's
true there could be a bit of mind games
going on here okay this is guaranteed
yep that is guaranteed on big bodies i
never knew that was has that always been
a thing from season yeah yeah i think it
has been yeah um that the can-cans in
that situation it kills the bears i
think jack and and
yeah yeah everything kills cat
yeah
all right nice first round that's solid
first round from wraith
and you know what's crazy bubsy that
first dan is much more uh i feel like
terrifying than the omega i know why
it's just so much scarier it's exactly
it lures you into full sense of security
i don't know what to expect here man
all right nice
go to the five star frog splash
banking up using that keep out
extra long limbs of gigas you can
actually see how long his arms are
yeah it's strange just that keypad game
using those jabs you're not down forward
one
yeah
nice nice yeah
i feel like that was going to be a big
um factor in this matchup that parry
versus uh gigas especially with bk using
that headbutt a lot unfortunately there
gets a tempering punish
okay just backing up
i don't want to commit to anything just
now oh
yeah let's talk about it doesn't want to
commit too much but gets counter hit
it's about to get so i like that yeah
let's be very careful hey he's against
the wall race does have rage
oh
okay this is down to can't get
conversions i can't hit
unless you
wow
called him out these guys have
definitely played before man rifle knew
exactly what bk was going to do there
and he actually matched after the rage
drive so it was a call out rave actually
jumped before the race drive actually
came out because he thought he had to
read their nice parry yeah
definitely ready for this one rafe
yeah one two three
guaranteed damage
there's so much damage and goes to the
health seat is the side moves back going
to save him no he knows the combo
i know this side who is coming i got the
combo right here i'ma dial it in right
now
yeah beautiful yeah it's so good there
from rafe and multiple scenarios yeah he
knew that that uh bk he did that in the
first match but remember he did the rage
driving he actually just waited um he
knew he's gonna do that punished him
with the two for using the parry
beautifully not spamming it not using it
too much but in certain scenarios where
he knows his timing he uses a parry and
gets a full launch the combos as well
with the can-cans everything's on point
here yes definitely and let's just i
just want to reiterate the point that
when jin uses his parry
it's not a guaranteed like punish on
like a shredder it's like he has to know
he looks like he's done like the
research because he knows exactly okay
this is
this this is guaranteed to shred his
guarantee sometimes you may do a move
and it's not guaranteed because it
recovers a lot quicker so it looks like
definitely he's done his homework here
probably definitely played together i
think because from when he jumped back
for the race drive like before and then
um bk kind of delayed his race drive and
done it after he landed
right like that shows that these two
have played each other before i i'll i'm
a better man i'm gonna put mine yeah
yeah for sure i mean and even if they
haven't like you can just see like the
the matchup knowledge that he has for
uh for 4k gases too is good but bk is a
very experienced player himself i know
that there were you could see that in
that match there was a potential
potential for him to get good punishment
yeah you can see that he was trying to
condition him with the down forward four
so gigas is down forward four one plus
two it's a kick into headbutt right yeah
and uh it's got like an 11 frame gap so
you can you can you can go for a jab or
or something to interrupt it and he was
trying to bait that out of race but rife
wasn't wasn't going for it um so like bk
i think there is some information that
he's gathered here and let's see if he's
able to apply it and he's gonna go to
the forgotten realm as well party stage
to try to get that maximum damage here
bubsy maximum damage let's see if he's
gonna try to do that speed run right
yeah what do you think 18.67 seconds
yeah 18.67 seconds guys it's the world
record for breaking all of the floors
and there's already three seconds past
it's not looking good no they can go to
the speed running okay here we go you're
going down oh it doesn't get the jab oh
yeah that was an unfortunate drop
there's gonna get to the wall yeah going
downstairs definitely now
all right
oh i thought we're gonna get a combo
video right there
and again all right just you know
oh nice good counter hit down four two
okay nice option not break the floor
and he gets caught floating now this
yeah he's gonna go downstairs we're
gonna get to the wall unfortunately
here we go
okay
oh boy oh no this is this is sometimes
well it happens sometimes it is online
you know it happens it's it's not it
does happen all the way does happen yeah
you know when like
lemon
lemonade
however right this might actually work
out in favor of uh of bk a little bit
because the momentum was there man
momentum was was really really uh in his
favor yeah with drive so who knows
what's going to happen in bk he's got a
thank allah for that man
because he was
he wasn't looking very good there man he
was all over him so let's see what
happens once we get we're going to get
back in later we will hopefully get back
on the same stage break the floor
whatever and reset uh with that but yeah
uh rifles all over in bubsy yeah
right like you said it's a blessing in
this in disguise and it gets a little
time to just cool down just
think like what happened what can i do
differently you know
um yeah
but i would say try and like it seems
like once rife gets going it's
i guess gigas so he needs to use the
long to lock the long reach of giga so
try and keep him out it seems like once
he gets that wave dash going and gets in
his face and puts him in that mix up you
know jin has a strong health sweep he
has a strong mid game and accident you
can launch him also has an electric so
you can pressure him he just kind of
needs to
mitigate and stop that and i guess gig
ass as well being a big character so
it's harder for him to step out of these
things
so once you have those kind of
characters you kind of need to think
okay so i can't step i need another
option to stop people just mauling me
down and that's when the long um limbs
come into play
yeah it's those arms right i think the
jab needs to be used a bit better here
from from bk um because right now rife
rife is getting in very easily is
allowing him to get in and pressure him
this matchup doesn't seem to be too good
for gigas to be honest but you have to
work around it by using the jab i think
that using the jab might be a because i
don't know if jin has that many uh high
crush tools bottom down four which is a
very consistent high crush i mean how
many high crushing tools does he have i
think the electric sometimes might be
able to go underneath the jab in some
scenarios but you know generally
speaking using the jab might be a very
good way to for him to just keep him out
keep him humble and at that time slow
down the match once the match is slowed
down then you guys can actually maybe
maybe get something started something
started i want to think maybe also um
gigas has that forward one plus two just
that head box sometimes there's a check
just oh yeah yeah yeah yeah just to you
know sometimes you have to be a little
bit disrespectful you know like we saw
it like way earlier on in the tournament
where um the i can't remember the link
player where he's using the standing
four against dragon off like just when
after the black one plus two like
sometimes you need to just
put a reality check and just see it out
there i think gigas says forward one
plus two is a good answer because once
you get that one card here it gives you
that position it pushes them towards the
wall and then you know it's a scary move
that's huge damage as well so maybe
utilize that a little bit more obviously
it's the highest it can be ducks you
need to be careful and use it sparingly
and accordingly like properly don't
don't use it too obviously because
i'm sure
um
it'll catch on to it for sure
but uh the players are coming back in
now ladies and gents uh once again thank
you for your patience thanks for waiting
we all want to see some second action
you know and we're going to get back
into it very shortly once again you know
uh tekken online challenge middle east
if you're just tuning in uh we're very
happy to be bringing you this because me
and bobsy were at the we were
commentating the uh the finals for the
the middle east the first master event
in dubai yeah that happened in 2019
rocks and roll dubai man it was a great
experience for us to go down there meet
a lot of the middle east players for the
first time and man i just i'm so sad
that we weren't able to do it in 2020
it's going to be in jordan yeah for the
marshall event for the fate of the fate
tournament but man hopefully soon man
hopefully soon next year you know like
hopefully next year we'll see that stuff
right so we're going back in and we're
probably gonna break one of the floors
as well because i feel like we broke one
of the floors uh they might not even
give a damn they're just going to reset
the round maybe but either way we're
coming back in here we go
rife did have the first round
yeah okay so yeah we are
i guess we're not probably gonna break
the floor but yeah
man
all right it's nice let's go
join them again we're going downstairs
yes
okay it looks like him before election
it doesn't duck the second hit of two
four big boo
nice conversion there
oh wavy wave
okay this time gets a flip over
guaranteed
yeah no duck ah he's not ducking that
yeah
used to try to fish for a counter hit
jab again four two once accounted big
with no no launch yeah that was a big
opportunity there could have got the
launch
put uh rafe in a bad position
hopefully he doesn't come back to haunt
him
that's why i talked about using that jab
he's not been using it too much he's
letting him get in and that's down to
gonna kill raj now on one round away
from moving on in this topic loses
exactly what we said before he needs to
try and keep him out listen once you get
in it's impossible to get him out
you know it's like blue tech in here
final destination what's the combo eight
eight okay it's nice
nice blocking the down too but just get
too full gets going to get that real
splat
but
messed up on the combo a little bit
yeah oh he's doubting himself now bubsy
he doesn't know what to do his mind is
boggled and that is gonna be it right if
with three rounds straight i'm gonna
eliminate bk from the tournament bk
though a top eight finish for him gotta
be proud with that but right if we'll
move on yeah it just seemed like that um
that gin pressure was just one